[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we talk about whatever
welcome back everyone 2021
we're fully in the 20s now do you think
now we're gonna start referring it to
like
you know in 21 oh yeah back at 21. you
know what's crazy is 2020 felt so long
that when i say back in 2019 it feels
like five years ago
it does that's true that was five years
ago instead of
two years ago we're in the roaring 20s
dude saying just saying like back in 18
is pretty cool too
back in 1980 man yeah you know how it
was
i think the last pandemic was around 19
19
1915 whatever i don't know we're in a
matrix
it just keeps repeating over and over
like oh the cycle finished
do it again true what do you think is
going to happen in the next 100 years
aliens wow that's already happening
what's going on with aliens
oh we're going to talk about that later
oh but if i want to know now can we just
talk about it a little bit tune in later
you're going to tune in later you got to
wait i want to see an alien
but i'll tune in later for that do you
guys have any like new year's
resolutions for this year or any well i
hate whenever people
talk about me what about goals or you
don't like goals
no i love vegetables i just don't see
them as resolutions
what's a resolution well i guess you
don't have to make it so resolution
sounding
but like do you have any like i want to
do i want to put on pants this year like
is there just like
things i want pants can we
look at the definition of a resolution
isn't it like how many pixels are on a
screen
yeah that's what i was thinking like i
want at least two thousand
what did you do okay clear picture well
the res a resolution
is a firm decision to do or not to do
something
oh that's what it means a formal
expression of opinion
or intention agreed on by a legislative
body committee or other formal meeting
typically
after taking a vote yeah cause i was
thinking that part like the more of a i
heard it in politics and lawmaking
yeah the reason why i hate it is because
i'm always like
all talk
like i i just hate that about myself you
know what i hate about promises i don't
keep them yeah
i don't keep it to myself let's get rid
of promises so i'm like [ __ ] i'm always
like
that's why january 1st i'm like here we
go again
oh my god that's dark i'm gonna i'm
gonna tell myself i'm gonna do some [ __ ]
so you already resoluted to break your
resolution so you actually won
no yeah but i always try but i don't
like
the concept of it because i feel like if
you have the desire why do you have to
wait
because what if what if i had a new year
resolution at january 3rd i have to wait
until 2022
january 1 to me to do a [ __ ]
that's my problem with it is that why is
it gonna be if you're a goal setter and
you're a goal person you should always
have goals you have goals that you're
like
you have your five year goal you have
your one year goal you have a couple
months goal
why do you have to wait till january
first it's for non-gold people nikki
it's for people who but they break it
anyway
but not necessarily hopefully you gotta
do is reprogram your habits not the
goals if you're
a type of person that can't keep your
goals you guys change your habits and
people don't focus on their habits
enough it's also because on new year's
eve you're supposed to get so
[ __ ] drunk and [ __ ] up that you're
you want to change your life yeah you're
late you're laying in a gutter or a
dumpster somewhere
and then you're like yeah how did i end
up here
okay these are my resolutions so barred
on one sip of wine
yes yeah yeah yeah and joe just smelling
alcohol
oh yeah what's your new year's
resolution be lazy
i didn't drink enough oh i gotta do it
what's yours since you brought it up
true um i think this year since we are
making the big move
like to vegas um i just want to
have a lot of fun times with our family
it looks like you're reading off a
script
i just wanna have a lot of fun i have
a gun under the table and i'm like you
better spend more time with this
[ __ ] does that mean you weren't
having fun
no because like 20 20 yeah he added the
family part to it
no because 2020 um you know we couldn't
really go
that many places i'm not my eyes are
wandering here but i'm not reading
anything
so in 2020 we could all of us couldn't
really go that many places
and also taika wasn't at the age where
he can like explore and enjoy things
so he's finally at the age where he can
like talk now if we have a campfire i
know he's going to stay away from it
so uh next year because we are going to
um be in a place where there's like like
nevada is right in between utah and like
a lot of cool states party time but i
want to do a lot of like camping a lot
of like road trips like that kind of
stuff
so kind of all the outdoor stuff that i
feel like i missed out on this year i
want to do
like with the family so your new year's
resolution is basically be outdoors more
yeah
yeah that's cool dude that's the sickest
new resolution i just want to have fun
yeah pretty much pretty much yeah
i like the idea of a resolution um
where it helps it gets me to focus on
something different for each year so
then like
you know you're not just aimlessly just
turning the wheel non-stop
and then you take a moment to go like
this year i just want to focus
on this and it doesn't always have to be
like this like
i gotta [ __ ] lose weight or work at
something that's why i have my weird
systems of colors and numbers that
already takes care of it it's kind of
like being zuckerberg and wearing the
same shirt every day or like
one of those or whatever yeah i've been
doing that i've been doing that
yeah he's definitely wearing the same
hat every day same shirt same hat but
for you man
well the thing is like if you compliment
steve you're like that's a good look for
you
he just will wear it every day forever
which is is great because it looks good
on him
but that's his this is his 2021 look
you look like you trade stocks thank you
you look good in hats a lot of people
there's yeah
some people don't that happens i mean
mattress is that close
thank you i like it uh this is my
football teams
and i and i and i actually i'm just
comfortable in hats now
um i like that style hat on you yeah dad
had this
this style he looks new england stick to
dad
new england he looks new england i'm not
drunk he looks like he's a
super rich [ __ ] tech guy that's
trying to tone it down he's
yeah silicon valley or new england dad
that likes sports
or a poker player if you have sunglasses
on oh yeah oh
where the sunglasses at complimenting
him too much is it too much
he needs it he's like a athlete
enthusiast he likes watching athletic
things
and he's a jock but a former jock no he
looks like someone you don't want to
talk sports with if you don't know
enough about
right oh i hate those guys actually
that's what you look like oh
no no no he's not he's he's the guy
that knows a lot about sports because he
gambles not because
he's a he's into sports so much that
he's fighting over
stuff at the bar that's pretty true i
don't gamble on sports
yeah you do fantasy football's con kind
of a gamble yeah it is kind of a gamble
i guess but it's like
we're talking about the image we're not
talking about the true steam cause it's
not a gamble if you never win
you have not won a single championship i
know i won a championship
it was 10 years ago but oh no
wait so what are the kind of people that
sound like they don't
like no like you can get stuck sometimes
talking to sports people
who know way too much about sports you
know every single stat of
everything from football related i think
i hate myself as well
[Laughter]
there you go good thing i love you how
about that bitcoin though huh
uh here we go bang bang bang it's eminem
for her
bitcoin for you eminem what are we
talking about eminem and i brought it up
on purpose so we wouldn't talk about
bitcoin oh no for me
yeah i saw a porno store you saw a porno
store
huge one did you go in i took a picture
outside of it because there was a
beautiful mural
on the on the side and then there was
creepy guys with one hand in their
pocket walking inside so i was like nope
can you uh eat indoors in las vegas yep
but you're gonna say can you eat
inside the porn store i was like what
remember when we went
to vegas like 10 years ago and we were
filming
and then we ran into the uh elvis and
then the elvis was giving us
recommendations for different strip
clubs with good buffets
yeah they have buffets at strip clubs do
you follow his recommendations
no we're like why would we go to a strip
club to eat at a buffet i'll go to the
circus circus what if it was a super
bomb and you just judged this elvis guy
and he knew exactly what he was talking
about yeah it was during a time when we
were so broke we couldn't afford a lap
dance
can you really just judge an elvis guy
though i think
he probably wouldn't know where the good
strip clubs are out of
all the people in vegas exactly it's
either cab drivers or the elvis guy
at the elvis sign or the guys with the
oh yeah those are cab drivers too huh
and i think at that time we were in our
uncle's costume so you saw an elvis and
two that's funny
why are you [ __ ] judge him yeah i
know how dare you judge that poor man
making a living and you guys looking
like
he was probably judging them dude
there's no guy in an elvis costume
watching this right now elvis no elvis
guy is in his costume right now being
like i remember when i
was walking around vegas with these two
guys and uncle costumes
king didn't know anything i love how he
knew that they were uncles though like
how does he know they're all he's a fan
he's been watching jk since the start if
you guys see the new animaniacs reboot
what you didn't know
oh no it's becca it's gonna be in your
head forever now wait i don't know the
dot is cute
and yeah yeah so yeah it's back and it's
actually pretty dope i remember this one
yeah wait is it reruns or they're doing
a new one no all the reruns
are also on hulu but they
did a reboot and there's like i don't
know remember the pigeons the good
fellows the good feathers
characters because they the reference
right the reference they don't get it
yeah it's all old 90s jokes but um so
the only character is still left are
pinky in the brain
but you get kind of sick of it because
they're in every single episode
so it's too much peaking in the brain
one is the genius
the others insane they try to rule the
world
there's something something it's pinky
and the break you know what pinkie used
to piss me
off i'm like how can you be so
like i was like stupid why are you even
his friend if you're so smart
you're [ __ ] dumb bro well there's a
conspiracy
that you know they say one's a genius
and the other's insane that it's
actually pinky that's the genius
oh and he's ruining this guy's plans for
world domination because he's saving the
world
saving the world and the other guy's
brain's insane
did you find this theory you know a
message boards don't ask me geo like
okay
i got a license you know what i got a
life today's sponsor is
upstart thank you very much because
upstart is something i wish i had
when i was in college i graduated with
like 40 grand in debt
and this was credit card debt the worst
debt of all baby like
16 apr that's just every single year i'm
only
paying the freaking i'm only paying the
interest meaning like
i'm not even i'm not even chipping away
at that debt
and i wish i had something like this to
just consolidate everything
and put it into one thing and be able to
like pay off my
uh debt much much faster because during
that time what i had to do
is i had to sign up with other credit
card companies that had zero apr
and do it that way but upstart made it
super simple
for everyone to get rid of their debt so
if you've been avoiding your debt it's
time to confront it upstart can help you
face it and
finally pay it off laster showed us that
you never know what life is going to
throw at you and if you use credit cards
to pay for unexpected expenses
it can be overwhelming to manage it can
be overwhelming to manage that debt take
control with upstart so you know exactly
what to expect
if you have multiple credit cards like
joe did you know that tracking multiple
balances
due dates and website logins can be
stressful
upstart makes things simple with one
monthly payment in one place
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple fixed monthly
payment
upstart finds smarter rates with trusted
partners because they assess more than
just your credit score
with a five minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front
your loans from 1 000 to 50 000
oh my god that would have helped me you
can get approved the same day
and can receive funds as fast as one
business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start with upstart
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today
with when you go to upstart.com
off the record upstart.com off the
record
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
off the record thank you so much upstart
for sponsoring
sponsoring off director get rid of that
debt oh that was a new year's resolution
for me um 2020 is get rid of that debt
no debt no debt no debt did you get it
yep nice
oh sick it was crazy too because um
i had about full disclosure about a
hundred and twenty-five thousand dollars
that i owed oh
[ __ ] that's why i started last night
okay
you know the reasons why [ __ ]
i'm a gambler baby
i'm proud of it we're proud of you man
how did you do it if you don't mind
disclosing
with upstart no no i mean like how did
he get the 125 in the first place i had
i had that and
it was a mixture of personal loans and a
bunch of other things and then
um so i actually
had the money um and i had more coming
along the way
because i just kept working my ass off
and saving and whatever right but i was
paying like
the minimum on it because i was afraid
that i wouldn't
continue making the same amount of money
but then um
i called well long story short i was
talking to my buddy
the mushroom king and he was looking at
my situation and he was like oh it's a
psychological issue it's not a money
issue
and i'm like what do you mean by that
and he goes well you're so um
burped from being in debt for so much
that you're actually you can probably
pay this off in like three months
wow but you are reluctant
to chipping away at that because you
want this reservoir of money
but he goes if you think about it though
the interest that you're building every
month that's thousands of dollars
so you could just wipe this out and be
confident that money is coming so
now you got to project how much is
coming and then i calculated and i was
like yeah and then i offset my expenses
and did a lot
a lot of other things um i mean i um
i cut my expenses and did a lot of other
things and then
um yeah it was it was he was right it
was basically
how i was looking at it i could have
done it already
but um my mind was preventing me to do
to not doing it because
i've been in debt for most of my life so
like
and some of it was good debt meaning
like it was debt because i was
investing or other things so um i never
saw it as a bad thing
until i caught myself in a bad situation
because i
i didn't factor in this calculation when
i went into an investment
so without getting too complicated the
way
that you can you get taxed is you get
taxed on your profits
what i was doing is i thought investing
into something
i would be able to write this off
meaning like it would balance out
but the thing that i put my money into
was not
attack uh a tax write-off so that's
that's for goddamn sure
that's for sure
right you're a [ __ ] legend bro but i
i'm fine and i'm on top
so that's the that's the that's the
beauty of it all is i went to hell and
back hell yeah and i recovered
yes hey that's hard and that's 20 20.
and i did it in three months
when i could have done it really good
when i was holding on to that for about
a year
so 2019 i was like way extra in interest
no no actually it occurred in 2019 oh no
no 20 sorry
20 18 on to 19. you mean 18 and 19. yeah
it was eight 2018 2019
and then 2020 was cleared out first
three months
yeah i laugh because i just think you're
the [ __ ] man dude
i i just think that it's so funny how
hard you go on [ __ ] sometimes like i
love it
it's something that i think is great
about you go harder go home yeah baby
it's beautiful do you have any going
hard plans for this year uh
in different ways so what i realized is
for me i just love the adrenaline rush
from risk right and that's what makes me
a gambler
but the things that i do sometimes have
dire consequences
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
which i can get the same fulfillment
direct consequences from heavy risk
that's crazy be surprised yeah well i
rather break
what i realize is i'd rather break a arm
than lose hundreds of thousands of
dollars
so i get the same enjoyment from going
downhill
extremely fast on a on a mountain bike
or like snowboarding it's just that
during those years i had to get my fix
somehow because i wasn't doing
those things those things so that outlet
manifested
in gambling in risky investments versus
um now i get my fulfillment elsewhere
like i can go snowboarding with my
buddies or whatever
so then i was like oh [ __ ] you know this
is it's a fraction of the cost and then
i can do it pretty safe relatively safe
like there is risk to injury but
you know i'm not pushing my limit to the
point where it's too much
right yeah whereas money my threshold is
higher
my limit is like i will push it
until i lose everything whereas in
extreme
is he a legend or what i mean that's
what i'm saying you're the legend
but i won't do that with extreme sports
right i'll look at something and i'll
assess it and i go that's too scary
so i'll get the same enjoyment but not
risking so much that makes sense because
you only need a little bit to get that
same fulfillment
yeah whereas money on the other hand
there's no limit if i had a million
dollars i'll risk it all
and i would have that and i would make
i'll go that was amazing
you're like all in why did you do that
you had a six and a two off suit
right but i'll do stupid things like
that and i was like well which one has a
bigger consequence
i rather just do the snowboarding and
stuff and i get the same joy
excitement the rush good for you holy
[ __ ] so now that you're
fully paid off are you doing dave ramsey
method or what
uh no i mean like i already have so it
was also perspective right like you're
getting an
investment in in for the past year now
you know like
you're you're using an investment like
an investor
i'm looking at it as a casino as a
gambler because i already have
ira meaning a retirement fund i already
have a lot of like
stocks like blue chip company stocks
already have that covered right and
that's like half of my money already
so i felt safe everything else i'm like
everything else
it's like playing money it's play money
but the consequences
is hundreds of thousands of dollars so
then when i look at it i go
[ __ ] i could have been let rent free for
the next 20 years
why the [ __ ] did i do that and then i
i'm like that was kind of dumb
and i don't like feeling that way but
now that you're safe do you feel like a
itch that you need to
risk it all again no because i i i have
snowboarding snowboarding i have my
fulfillment elsewhere if you saw all of
us at the crafts table and we're like
we're going in
he's going in for sure oh yeah yeah but
i what i realized is i get the same
excitement with a
couple thousand dollars at the crab
staple and
with hundreds of thousands of dollars
elsewhere i get the same excitement so
then i'm like i didn't have to do that
is it because it's cash and you see like
because cash always feels like more
money than like when you're in the
electronically sending stuff yeah
it's like 200 is like wow yeah i don't
want to lose 200.
like just holding tens of thousands of
dollars cash
has more of an effect than looking at a
bank account with zeros
psychologically like most people would
be like that's [ __ ] ridiculous i'd
rather have ten zeros behind that one
it makes sense but the emotional effect
that you get from like
seeing this yeah and you're like yeah
this is [ __ ]
crazy right versus like maybe just
numbers
yeah so i i think it was more like just
just
changing my perspective on things so i'm
not really
risky like that but i gotta say that one
day i do want to
genuinely do this take like 10 grand and
bet it on like the [ __ ] super bowl
and just sit there and have the greatest
[ __ ] game or worst of my life
from the beginning of the super bowl or
from before we even know who's in the
super bowl
oh no i have to know who's in the super
bowl so that i i got a fair shot
that sounds epic i think you should do
it yeah i think you should [ __ ] do it
to me
it's all relative right like if you're a
millionaire that's like
gambling five bucks true so that's why
give a percentage then
give a percentage because for me i'm
like 80 percent
gambling my life and then 20 is like
what i have
holy cow so that's why i got to stop
doing that wow
so 2021 i'm not doing that no more yeah
love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you